I I got hurt I got hurt three times once
significantly I tore all my uh tricep or
I tore my tendons in my tricep doing a
movie and so then I and then the recent
movie yeah the machine you know his own
Motion Picture coming out yes it is this
whole Ukrainian Russia thing cleans
itself up yeah yeah yeah we're kind of
in a holding power
and oh my God yeah because because the
machines are in Russia because they're
killing Ukraine I was planning on a
Premiere in Moscow and oh did I find it
on that cartoon coming out ripping his
shirt off
let me fight let me fight Fedor in the
opening you know who's in our movie
who's that uh
um uh [ __ ] Brittany grenner no
uh UFC champion UFC number six uh
uh
um
white guy Russian Russian dude he's a
Russian dude now uh uh uh
Oleg hey he was he was he was reached
out to me he was dming me when I was
fighting fatal he's like dude say these
no Carolina he's like say these things
this guy
is one of the funnest hangs is he really
ever been around no way one of the
coolest dudes
I meet him I meet him and he uh we're
watching a soccer game at a at a bar at
a hotel in Russia in no in in Serbia and
he's uh and he's having like cold beers
but you know like like really enjoying
these like uh slides uh try like like
gym shorts casual like real real casual
but it's still in really great shape
he's in great shape and he's having
beers and he goes uh hey I I know your
buddy huh and I was like yeah and he
goes uh Rogan and I was like oh yeah and
then I realized oh [ __ ] I don't I didn't
realize who I was talking to I Knew and
I was like oh [ __ ] I watched you fight
so immediately he goes call him and I
was like done [ __ ] FaceTime Rogan I'm
like Rogan and he's like holy [ __ ] and
like they [ __ ] go off oh that's cool
and then we every time he showed up on
set that guy was the funnest dude that's
so dope but like but like and he's an
amazing actor really like dude like the
smallest things that you'd go in in a
movie where you'd go
I don't want to spoil too much but the
smallest things he would make them like
it would make it his own he's so [ __ ]
good dude I that that's heartbreaking
that that the Russia Ukraine war is
delaying that that is that bums me the
[ __ ] out but that's how I I tore all my
tendons and I had to get surgery yeah
zipper on it let me see that thing
oh not too bad I mean he had a horseshoe
before that didn't you know
little kicker back yeah yeah I know and
so I got I I don't even know what that
means the uh but but that made me gain I
got to 265. I was 240 shooting the movie
the whole time
foreign